This episode is sponsored by Endel, an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to help
you focus, relax and sleep.
The first 100 people to click our description
link will get a one week free trial.
An ambiguously long time ago, there was this
theory of medicine.
It was called the Doctrine of Signatures,
and it persisted for centuries,
maybe even millennia.
The liverworts we’re looking at right now
are a prime example of how this system conceptualized
nature and medicine.
The premise of the Doctrine of Signatures
was so simple that honestly,
we wish it were true.
The idea was that if you came across a plant
that looked like a body part, that meant it
was meant to treat ailments that targeted
said part.
In the 17th century, an English physician
named Nicholas Culpepper said this of liverwort:
It is a singular good Herb for all the diseases
of the Liver, both to cool and cleanse it.
All this pressure put on one tiny plant, simply
because it resembled the liver.
Unfortunately, it turns out that medicine
is a little more complicated than the
Doctrine of Signatures.
But even though liverworts cannot cure all
the diseases of the liver, it’s still remarkably
talented, capable of cloning itself in a series
of steps that sound like they came right out
of science fiction.
To get a sense of what liverworts look like
in nature, we can actually turn back to
Nicholas Culpepper’s writing:
THe Common Liverwort, groweth close and spreadeth
much upon the ground in moyst and shadowy
places, with many sad green leaves, or rather
(as it were) sticking flat one to another,
very unevenly cut in on the edges, and crumpled,
from among which arise smal slender stalks
an Inch or two high at most, bearing smal
Starlike Flowers at the tops:
The Roots are very fine and smal.
The flowery structures and roots that Culpepper
described might make you think that liverworts
are just a normal plant.
But liverworts are bryophytes—
a loosely associated group of ancient but
tiny plants that don’t have the vasculature
we think of when we think of flowering plants.
Without vascular structures like a xylem or
phloem to transport nutrients and water around,
bryophytes can’t grow quite as tall.
Instead, liverworts and their bryophyte compatriots,
including mosses, tend to grow only a few
centimeters tall.
Even though they’re super low to the ground,
liverworts make quite an impression.
For one, they're bright green, filled with
chlorophyll to help them perform photosynthesis.
But if you scan along the surface of some
liverwort species, you might notice weird
parts where the cells seem to warp and turn
in a strange way, their insides filled with
little discs made out of plant tissue.
Why?
We’ll get back to that in a bit.
There are two types of liverworts.
The less common kind are called leafy liverworts
because of their leafy scales and flat stems.
These liverworts look a lot like moss, but
their leafy structures are distinct enough
that those who know what to look
for can distinguish the two.
The other kind of liverworts are thalloid
liverworts, which look more like scaly structures
stretching out across the ground.
When Culpepper described liverworts as having
small, fine roots, he was almost correct.
Liverworts do have small, hairy structures
that help it latch onto surfaces.
These structures are called rhizoids, unlike
roots, they aren’t able to absorb nutrients
from their surroundings.
These rhizoids are fascinating to look at
because each one is a single cell, stretched
out long and able to hold the liverwort in
place.
Another feature that distinguishes bryophytes
like the liverwort from vascular plants is
that they don’t reproduce with seeds.
Instead they rely on spores for sexual reproduction.
To make this happen, liverworts have two distinct
stages to their life.
They begin as a gametophyte, with sperm-producing
structures called antheridia and egg-bearing
structures called archegonia.
The antheridia produce sperm, which travels
through water to find the archegonia on another
liverwort so that it can fertilize the eggs
there.
And when that fertilization happens, a new
stage of liverwort emerges into the world
called a sporophyte.
It will continue developing in the archegonia
until it’s ready to release spores into
the world, which will develop into a
new gametophyte, carrying on the cycle.
That process is so sweet and familiar:
an egg and a sperm meet, and from there an
entity develops into a life, expanding the
world of liverworts just a little bit further.
But thalloid liverworts are capable of reproducing
by another means, a weirder one.
All they need is a cup and some rain.
Remember that green swirl we saw earlier?
That structure is on the surface of the liverwort,
and it’s called the gemma cup.
Its job is to hold little discs of liverwort
tissue called gemmae.
The gemma cup and its little gemmae form during
the gametophyte stage, but they don’t do
anything at this point.
The gemmae are simply dormant.
So what does it take to awaken the gemmae?
Rain.
Seriously, that’s it.
When rain pours onto the liverwort, it splashes
the gemmae out of its cup and carries them away.
And as they travel, the gemmae emerge from
their slumber so that eventually, when they
find a place to land, they become a new plant.
Though maybe “new” is the wrong way to
put it.
They’re actually a clone of the old one,
born from just a little disc carried in a
cup and pushed out with just a dash of rain.
We have seen so many versions of asexual reproduction
in the microcosmos, and they often feel kind
of violent—
or at least painful, if microbes felt the
pain of tearing themselves apart into two
identical clones.
In comparison, the liverwort’s method feels
so sweet, like it’s just packing its little
future selves for a rainy journey.
It’s a version of clones and asexual reproduction
that we probably wouldn’t have conjured
up in our wildest science fiction imaginations.
It’s adorable.
A little bit of rain falls in a cup, and out
comes a sleepy clone, ready to wake up and
spread its wings, or, I suppose, its non-vascular
body, into the world.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Endel for sponsoring
this episode.
Endel is an environment-based app that takes
everything we know about sound and combines
it with cutting-edge technology.
The result is real-time, personalized soundscapes,
designed to help you relax, focus, and sleep.
Sound has a direct impact on your physical
and mental wellbeing, and with their patented
core technology, Endel can adapt in real-time
to things like your location, weather, and
heart rate to create simple, pleasant sounds.
You can use Endel to calm your mind and help
you concentrate for longer periods of time
when studying or working or soothe you into
a deep sleep with soft, gentle sounds.
If you’re interested in trying out Endel,
just be one of the first 100 people to download
it using the link in the description and you
will get a free week of audio experiences!
Those names you’re seeing on the screen
right now are some of our Patreon patrons,
and they're the reason that this show can
exist.
If you’d like to join them in supporting
Journey To The Microcosmos, you can go to
patreon.com/journeytomicro to get weekly
wallpapers and monthly uncut videos
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes, James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram.
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.